[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're actually going to
be discussing a theory within the
greater wizarding world that is to say
today we'll be going for a deep dive
into the latest trailer from the
upcoming fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore film which was released a few
weeks back in december like many teasers
and trailers from a short three-minute
compilation of clips from the movie
there is much to unpack
despite its length which is why in this
video
i've decided to focus on one particular
part of the trailer why in the name of
merlin's beard does jacob have a wand
let's start off with a bit of background
for those of you who may not know the
jacob i'm referring to here is jacob
kowalski an american muggle or no
manchester state signed who was
introduced in the first fantastic beast
film and who has remained a main
character throughout these subsequent
sequels
in the first installment jacob is
befriended by newt's commander a quirky
major zoologist and the future author
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and taken on the magical adventure of a
lifetime in their travels jacob is
introduced to queenie goldstein a witch
and gifted legitimates being a
legilimens she's able to read people
hearing their thoughts and feeling their
emotions in queenie's case without even
trying
jacob and queenie quickly become
interested in one another and despite
jacob's memories being wiped at the end
of the last film by the second movie the
two have been reunited and are at the
very least dating
i say at the very least as when we first
see the pair in the crumbs of
grindelwald film queenie claims that the
two are engaged to be married however
newt soon uncovers that queenie has
enchanted jacob in order to get them
down the aisle
you see although jacob loves queenie
very much he's unwilling to marry her
for in doing so she would have been
imprisoned as marrying a nomad was
illegal in the united states at the time
unfortunately for these two lovebirds
after newt lifts the enchantment jacob
and queenie get into a fight queenie
deceptrates to paris to find her sister
tina
newt to jacob after finding a postcard
tina had sent queenie from paris head to
france in pursuit of the two sisters of
course there are a few other reasons the
pair head to paris but those details
will have to wait for another video
quite a bit transpires in paris but for
this theory all we need to mention is at
the end of the film queenie is lured
into becoming a follower of grindelwald
seduced by the promise of being able to
love and marry whomever she chooses such
as a nomad like jacob of course this is
terribly misguided
as grindelwald is infamous for his
anti-muggle sentiments and beliefs that
muggles are beneath wizarding kind but
apparently queenie doesn't view it this
way
which brings us to the upcoming secrets
of dumbledore film
in the trailer queenie looks to be quite
comfortable and might add powerful in
the service of kellett grindelwald and
jacob intent on getting her back and
still in the company of newt is given a
wand by dumbledore by way of mr
scamander
this brings us to the question
why give jacob a wand and who on earth
does it belong to
here are a few theories i've come up
with so far
theory one the wand is real and jacob
has some magical qualities as there are
varying levels of magic present in every
which or wizard could it be possible
that dumbledore has sensed that jacob
possesses a small amount of magical
power with this wand suppose he could
learn to channel minor magic and use it
for simple spells such as hagrid did
with his umbrella in harry potter
these would be spells he could use to
protect himself and his friends in times
of dire need
there's also the possibility that even
with no magical power dumbledore thought
it's safer to give jacob a functioning
wand that could expel chaotic magic in
desperate times because a real one even
when used by a muggle always produces
magic just not always with the desired
effects this theory is supported by the
quick glimpse we get in the trailer of
jacob looking like he's attempting to
use the wand in an encounter with
queenie theory two the wand is nothing
more than a prop used to disguise jacob
as a wizard as it's been well
established that jacob is in fact a
no-maj throughout the previous films
it's quite unlikely that he possesses
any magical talent
so perhaps he's been given a fake wand
just to help him blend in within the
wizarding world
after all in the trailer we see jacob in
a few different magical settings
including hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry that way if he were to
encounter a bad lot of witches or
wizards say grindelwald's acolytes he
could at least feign that he was a
wizard maybe even pretend to be one who
supported grindelwald and escaped the
meeting unscathed because without a wand
he would likely just be a sitting duck
no wand no magic no madge no chance
theory 3 the wand is real and can be
used by the others if they are disarmed
perhaps newt and damodar have given
jacob a proper functioning wand in the
event that they get taken by a group of
grindelwald's followers in this scenario
the assumption would be that the
acolytes being quite powerful witches
and wizards in their own right would be
able to tell that jacob is a muggle
and so they would disarm newt and the
other wizards but they wouldn't think to
check jacob for a wand after all why
would a muggle be carrying one so now
newt and the others would have a wand
concealed on jacob ready for them to use
when the opportunity presented itself
the scene from the trailer that i
mentioned in theory number one of jacob
encountering queenie while wielding his
wand could also have been interpreted as
him getting ready to throw the wand to
newt or another wizard
theory number four the wand is of great
value and dumbledore is using jacob to
hide it in plain sight one final thought
i have to answer the question of why
jacob would have a wand is that perhaps
it is actually a very important one one
that dumbledore wishes to hide somewhere
grindelwald wouldn't think to look for
it after all a powerful wizard like
grindelwald who so believed in the
superiority of pure-blooded wizards and
their domination over humanity would
hardly think to look for something of
importance in the possession of a muggle
he would never think to entrust
something of great value to someone
without magic so he might not be able to
conceive that anyone else could either
which brings us to one more question if
the wand is in fact a real wand who does
it belong to you may remember that the
wand chooses the wizard as the wand
maker olivander so gravely told harry
potter before he entered his first year
at hogwarts
i suppose the one given to jacob could
be some random unclaimed wand that has
yet to choose its master one which
dumbledore has borrowed from the wand
maker shop
of course if the wonders are fake and
more of a prop to help jacob blend in as
we discussed in theory number two then
it wouldn't have an owner but for theory
number four if the wand is an important
one who could it belong to that would
make it a wand of great value we know
from the harry potter series and
supporting materials such as
illustrations from the tales of beadle
the bond that this wand is not the elder
wand as that exceptional wonder was
quite unassuming in appearance made of
elderwood with a core of thestral hair
also in the secrets of dumbledore
trailer it would appear that grindelwald
is in possession of a wand that closely
resembles the elder wand as depicted in
the harry potter films the one given to
jacob on the other hand neither matches
the description of the elder wand in the
books nor the appearance of it as
presented in the harry potter films so
whose one could this be if it were an
important one could it be that it's
grindelwald's original wand before he
got his hand on the elder wand i suppose
we'll have to wait for the film to
release in the spring to find out the
answer
and with that we've made it to the end
of this video
what do you think why has jacob been
given a wand whose one could it be
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember
imperfect understanding is often more
dangerous than ignorance
[Music]